it's been almost a year since the world
changed forever not that anyone still
human had really been counting the days
almost a year since the sun forsook its
children and changed its Rays from
life-giving gifts to flesh melting
weapons more fitting of Hell than heaven
in the first hours of the chaos billions
were changed irreparably into
Abominations of Flesh that day when day
broke permanently altered the course of
history the remaining Personnel at the
SCP Foundation classified it
scp-001 but what good could they do now
it was for all intents and purposes the
end of the world as we knew it would
anything ever be as it was before no
in all likelihood the World As We once
knew it is little more than a dying
memory in the minds of those who even
bother remembering the times before
they'll do little to help you in this
terrible new reality we're even stepping
outside can be a gateway to a fate so
much worse than death huge fleshy
monsters Slither through the streets day
and night ceaselessly hunting for more
victims to drag out into the horrors of
daylight and join their ever-growing
forms when it happened planes fell out
of the sky like deadly hailstones
devastating the ground underneath in a
volley of explosions that left so much
of our world scarred cars and trucks
careened off the road and into buildings
and ditches as their drivers exposed by
the windows around them took on a liquid
state the surviving humans are in hiding
many like you or me want to survive and
be safe for another day others who lost
their minds during the change or perhaps
were always cruel in Monsters Underneath
It All lurked in the darkness waiting
for others they could destroy with no
law or order to stop them from indulging
in their worst Pleasures now anyone who
had survived this long was smart lucky
or some cursed combination of the two
one Wanderer named David didn't quite
know which group he'd classify himself
as he wandered through what had once
been the streets of New York City every
inch of his body covered up with a
special anti-sung suit of his own making
in the early days the SCP Foundation had
Mass release tutorials on how to build
full coverage suits out of clothes and
everyday household objects this had
likely saved many lives or at least
served to extend them for a while
sometimes that was the best you could
hope for David knew where he was going a
nearby underground parking complex
completely covered up beneath the Earth
where no natural light would reach the
people down there had constructed their
own generators to have working
electricity from emergencies and blocked
off any stairs or roadways to another
level the only way up or down was a
single Elevator Shaft that they owned
and operated it was the best way to keep
one of those Blobby monsters from
descending and dragging them all up to
the horrors of daylight David found the
place definitely avoiding any of the
monsters still roaming the streets he'd
been out on a food run collecting canned
goods from distant bodegas tuna spam hot
dogs soups they sent out four scavengers
a day in hopes of keeping Their Food
Supplies well stocked drawing straws
each day to decide fairly today David
had been one of them and it had been a
good day insofar as any day can be good
in this world on some days when they'd
sent out four scavengers only one two or
none at all had returned such is the way
with the world of the broken Sun you
quickly lost your sense of what's fair
if you wanted to survive here David had
learned that the hard way he reached the
elevator powered by the generators below
and knocked the secret code onto the
metal to get the doors to open He
Slipped inside and once the security
camera above saw it was him it descended
soon enough he was with the others
handing in the knights taking so they
could pool their resources and the most
experienced Cooks among them could
prepare tonight's dinner they took small
Pleasures in life whenever they could be
found later that same evening David and
four others Gus Addison Charlie and Mike
sat around a campfire eating cooked spam
out of their respective cans with
scavenged Forks they did all they could
to contact the world outside posting
messages online coded audio over any
working radio and ham frequencies even
leaving notes out in the open with Clues
to their location where the blobs whose
Minds were as melted and warped as their
bodies could never find them they
received correspondences from all over
the new world and with them came plenty
of interesting new stories to share so
that was precisely what they did around
the underground campfire every night
using filters they'd stolen from above
to keep the air pure they told each
other stories Gus had heard an
interesting one apparently out west
there was some kind of monster a
sculpture made out of concrete and rebar
that only moved when you weren't looking
at it this Beast stalked through the
dark seemingly indestructible and would
snap the necks of anyone and everyone it
managed to get its Rusty stretches of
rebar on in the world before this would
have seemed impossible but here and now
they were willing to believe it Charlie
told the story of a different Beast they
heard Tales of a group of people who
were holed up inside a mall in
Pittsburgh trying to wait out the
horrors nobody brought up the Dawn of
the Dead reference lurking in there but
apparently something else was lurking in
there too one day everyone who'd been
hiding in the mall was attacked and
slaughtered by some horrifying reptile
that tunneled out of the ground with
giant Claws and murdered almost all of
them in Cold Blood the one that escaped
had been telling his story to anyone who
listened nobody knew where the giant
reptile would turn up next Addison tried
to introduce a note of Hope with her
story she'd heard that out there there
was some mad genius working on a cure a
man who always wore a black cloak and a
white mask like one of those
old-fashioned plague doctors he'd come
closer than anybody else to synthesizing
a cure and he and all the others with
him were holed up in an SCP Foundation
site accepting help from anyone who
happened to wander by it would certainly
be a nice story if it were true but
nobody could really know for sure could
they Mike added a note of caution with
his story he'd heard of another group of
survivors who made their way to one of
those so-called SCP Foundation sites but
they'd found it abandoned devoid of the
many experts and saviors at the SCP
Foundation had promised in all of those
old broadcasts instead they were greeted
by a nightmare a ghoulish old man
covered in black slime with a permanent
sadistic grin on his face he could walk
through walls and melt off skin with his
burning touch he's always out there just
waiting for more unfortunate hope-filled
victims to fall into his clutches that
sent a shutter through them all what had
happened of course there was the obvious
problem of the treacherous burning Sun
up above and its melted minions down
below but how had the world suddenly
become so beset with these terrible
monsters it was like the Gates of Hell
had opened and all manner of beasts had
come spilling out all that the human
race could do now was survive but every
day the world seemed a little less worth
surviving for why were they here just to
be prey for these nightmare creatures
David who had been silent up to this
point finally spoke up asking have any
of you heard of the black Warrior there
was silence none have heard of this one
before they waited and listened he saved
my life David went on and I'd guess I'm
not the only one the incident as David
told it had happened weeks ago before
he'd even joined up with this current
group he'd lost everything and everyone
and was left wandering the wastes of New
York City alone he'd been hiding in the
dark of an old Financial building for so
long but his food supply had run
completely dry he would simply need to
leave he knew that if he waited any
longer even a few more hours without
food he'd pass out and dive starvation
in this sleep or be killed by one of
those things he'd need to go out in
daylight and forage it was the only way
he'd already built a total covered suit
what did he have to lose that very
thought would bring him closer to death
than he'd ever been before David
wandered out half Delirious with Hunger
trying to find a store that hadn't been
looted or burned down to nothingness his
vision was hazy he needed something to
eat and ideally something to drink too
he felt happier than he'd ever
remembered being when he came across an
abandoned Japanese grocery store and
filled up on stale rice and several
bottles of ramen like some congoing
teenager however while he may have just
saved his life in one way he'd put it in
grave danger in another the second he
stepped out of the store one of those
giant terrible flesh monsters saw him
his heart almost stopped as this
mountain of rancid liquefied meat
slithered towards him had shocking speed
sprouting a series of long tendrils
ready to grab him tear off his suit and
add him to its terrible Collective
trying to save his own life had
seemingly killed him of course David
tried to run but it was already too late
he felt the tendrils grab him and lift
him into the air pulling him towards the
immense and terrible flesh of this
rampaging super organism it called out
in so many warped voices at once crying
for terrible Unity David knew that in
Miram it would tear off his suit and
suddenly he'd be worse than dead but it
seemed that luck was about to shine on
him in the strangest of ways every
single one of the flesh monsters
gibbering voices became unified in the
blood curdling scream something swung
down and cleaved the mountain in half
splitting it cleanly into two smaller
blobs the tendrils immediately retracted
and David was dropped to the ground as
the two smaller shrieking blobs
slithered off terrified in different
directions at first David had no idea
what had just happened as he began
picking himself up from the ground then
he saw the silhouette of a mighty figure
standing a few feet away holding a
bigger sword than he thought would be
possible for a normal human to carry but
this was no normal human if it was human
after all he stood seven feet tall built
like an old marble statue every single
inch of his body was covered in obsidian
armor completely protecting the warrior
underneath from the oppressive rays of
the on this was the figure that David
and all the others who'd encountered him
had taken to calling the black Warrior
nobody knew who he was underneath all
they knew was that he wandered the new
world day and night slaughtering the
beasts of the sun he feared nothing and
everyone else knew to fear Him David was
on his back staring with disbelief at
the black Warrior the warrior exhaled
and began to walk towards him David
coward as he approached but the Warriors
simply kept walking past him confused
and Delirious with a mix of fear and
relief David called out wait aren't you
gonna kill me without breaking a stride
the black Warrior replied well as the
honor in stomping on ants and with that
he was gone he'd saved David's life and
then compared its value to that of an
ant that was the black Warrior it seemed
he was neither a hero nor a villain in
this new world just a man looking to
pick a good fight and from the
casualness with which he performed every
action even cleaving the abominable
flesh monsters it was likely he hadn't
faced an opponent he considered worthy
yet once David had told his story there
was silence around the campfire David
would never know if the others had
believed his story or whether they
thought it was just the ramblings of a
terrified man who'd just gotten lucky
but we know that David wasn't lying
about the black Warrior of course that
was a relatively recent name for him the
SCP Foundation had known him mainly as
scp-076-2 but to himself he was always
able it had been Abel's second
Resurrection into the world of when day
breaks in his first he decided to do
something bold and daring he'd storm
sight 19 at its weakest moment forcing
several other anomalies to assist him in
his bloody quest to strike back against
the SCP Foundation he'd followed and
taunted Dr Jack Bright then beaten this
Immortal of his own creation within an
inch of his latest life bright however
had managed to get the jump on Abel by
transferring his soul into the body of
one of those flesh Abominations then
using his Collective Strength to crush
Abel to death of course for Abel just
like Dr bright death had only ever been
a temporary inconvenience several months
later he'd once again resurrected from
his black sarcophagus his mind still
swimming with the memories of his last
life he wandered out into the now empty
containment area 25b littered with the
bodies of the guards and researchers
he'd killed during his last Escape
pathetic they'd posed no challenge what
would however pose a challenge to him
would be the sun outside he remembered
last time that the sun had somehow
changed now anyone exposed to its Rays
would be melted into one of those things
Abel was intelligent enough to realize
that this was something he might not be
able to regenerate from he needed a more
permanent solution but Abel had spent
his last several thousand years walking
this Earth coming up with extremely
permanent solutions to all of his
problems and this would be no except
he would need to wear armor armor that
covered every inch of his skin it would
be the only way he could move safely out
there of course he wouldn't be caught
dead in the Garb of the SCP Foundation
his pathetic would-be jailers who had
fallen in droves in the face of this new
threat he would make his own armor the
only way he could in case anyone needs a
refresher one of Abel's primary
anomalous abilities in addition to his
ability to resurrect himself and his
superhuman strength speed durability and
combat prowess it's his innate ability
to pull a limitless number of obsidian
weapons out of miniature localized
pocket Dimensions swords axes clubs
chainsaws scythes Spears hooks maces
flails tridents knives Cleavers almost
anything you can imagine but Abel's
deadliest weapon of all was his brain
and it was with that and a combination
of all his other weapons that Abel would
figure the perfect way out of this
situation first of all he produced a
mountain of weapons within the site a
huge pile that would make an army of
medieval knights go weak at the knees
but he would not use these weapons for
their intended purpose instead he went
about searching the building for
materials he could use in his brand new
project all he needed was sufficient
metal he could Bend into place and a
blast furnace one that he would eagerly
use the site's built-in nuclear warhead
designed for the explicit purpose of
killing him during an escape to instead
facilitate his new life in this new
world what a wonderful plan it was
shaping up to be it took him several
days to achieve his goal and a few
humiliating failures along the way but
Abel was eventually able to create a
sufficiently robust furnace to melt down
the many weapons he'd pulled from The
Ether and begin to make something new
out of their molten extracts Abel was a
holistically brilliant Warrior and to
achieve that title one can not only
learn how to fight but how to maintain
one's Arsenal and how to be an Adept
Smithy the latter skill would serve Abel
well here he used his own molten weapons
to construct the perfect battle armor
armor that would cover his body entirely
and protect him from the deadly sun
above he made several prototypes testing
each one by dressing up one of the many
Foundation corpses in it and pushing it
out into the Sun the first few soon had
liquefied human leaking out of its seams
so Abel knew he needed to iterate and
improve thankfully despite what his
bloodthirsty demeanor might tell you
able could be very patient when he
needed to be especially when that
patience could lead to Greater Bloodshed
down the line more weapons more melting
more forging more improving little by
little Abel was building himself the
perfect suit to venture out into the
sunlight and find new prey new battles
new violence he couldn't be happier with
the results soon enough Abel Found A
variation that prevented even his dead
test subjects from melting it was
perfect he even melted down the tinted
glass of some of the foundation tactical
Riot helmets to give his own Helm a
black visor just in case he had done it
and now with his new armor assembled and
worn on his huge muscular body he was
ready to go out there and make a new
name for himself even if all those who
remembered Abel were gone the others
would remember the black Warrior forever
in reverence and fear Abel produced a
new sword to go with his new look a
massive weighted double-sided Beast of a
blade one that almost nobody but able
would be able to carry a sword that
would be part of his Legend forevermore
oh this would be so much fun for the
first time since day had broken that
anybody had done so Abel stepped out
into the sunlight and smiled now go
check out scp-001 when daybreaks Dr
bright and scp-001 when daybreaks
scp-682 for more terrifying Tales from
the world of when day breaks